pause Canada n'a pas fermé la porte au
Publisac après un projet pilote de 2
mois l'automne dernier pour faire
distribuer les circulaires par les
facteurs la livraison devrait reprendre
sous peu à Montréal
informé que il y avait un retour
imminent des publics le syndicat déplore
un manque de transparence et l'absence
de plan pour faciliter la tâche au
postier leur boucle ces trajets où il
porte le courrier ont été alourdis par
les publicités et on atteint des boucles
après de 300 livres 300 livres c'est 10
fois à revenir aller sur recharger et
les outils n'étaient pas là selon le
syndicat la nouvelle formule diviserait
le poids du Publisac par 4 c'est
réduisent le poids il enlève beaucoup de
compagnies qui mettaient leur publicité
à l'intérieur du public sac qui vont
probablement maintenant
donner la charge à post-canada donc on
va les avoir inévitablement ces
circulaires là post-canada se contente
de dire que l'examen de nos processus
est toujours en cours afin de déterminer
les meilleures solutions possibles pour
assurer la sécurité de notre personnel
et mieux servir les can les Canadiennes
aucune date n'est précisée Montréal a
adopté un règlement qui interdit la
distribution sans consentement il
entrera en vigueur le 17 mai et rien
n'indique pour l'instant qu'il sera
respecté si Transcontinental et passe
canal vont de l'avare il bafoue la
volonté des Montréal est et nous on a
été là pour le mettre dans un règlement
qui j'aimerais ça qu'on respecte
l'autonomie des villes également
l'opposition y voit un manque de
leadership de l'administration c'est
important comme le fédéral et est
démontrer à quel point c'est pas dans
notre volonté d'avoir le publissac
France continental affirme que plus de
100000 foyers refusent le Publisac à
Montréal 90% des boîtes aux lettres sont
donc encore ouvertes au circulaire sauf
mention contraire ici Mathieu Prost
Radio-Canada Montréal